winter was like one of the greatest
Subarus out there but people don't know
where origin like you know Superman's
origin in Batman's origin and so what we
want to do in the film is really tell
people who she is where she comes from
and why she does what she does and we've
never seen on film before she comes from
a Greek mythology she was born on this
island of Amazon's called the mascara
we're gonna see her coming of age the
entire history was her mission these
Amazon's were once created to protect
man's world but they since abandoned it
and Diana is asking constantly why don't
we go through what we were created to do
and protect men and they say because
they're not worth it and this takes her
on a journey into our world telling a
story like this now is pivotal and
important destroy of a very powerful
woman she's an Amazon warrior she's the
best fighter in the DC Universe
she has strength and speed and she's
been training her whole life for war
Wonder Woman who's been around for 75
years feminist cultural icon she stands
for quality and that's really important
I think that's why people love the
character the greatest thing about
Wonder Woman is how good and kind and
loving she is yet none of that negates
any of her power
you
hey youtubers is Charlie DC week
continues we finally got our first look
at Wonder Woman so this is just the
first teaser trailer we probably won't
see the next really big one until
Suicide Squad drops later this year but
still plenty of stuff to break down it
might sound funny that people don't
really understand Wonder Woman's
character but but in reality like when
you look at the history of comics Wonder
Woman pales in comparison in terms of
popularity to Batman and Superman like
DC made its fortunes on the backs of
Batman and Superman everything else is a
distant second add to that that they've
changed Wonder Woman's origin story a
couple times in the comics and it does
get really confusing so like if you read
the Golden Age comics then she attains
her secret identity from a different
person named Diana Prince that's kind of
like her version of Clark Kent the alias
that she uses but that was an actual
person that she borrowed the identity
from she meets Steve Trevor because he
crashes near Paradise Island and that
kind of brings her into the world now
Steve Trevor in the movie is being
played by Chris Pine and they're setting
it in World War one the reason they're
setting it during World War one is
because the circumstances surrounding
that war lend themselves to the idea
that she is a great advocate for peace
you can kind of see how that figures
into Batman V Superman they're gonna be
at war with each other she's probably
gonna be the one to talk sense into both
of them to try and help make peace a lot
of times in the comics she's all about
making peace between the Amazons in the
outside world but a big part of World
War one was vicious colonial expansion
so she has to find a way to be a symbol
for peace for both her people who have
abandoned the rest of the world in the
outside world who just wants to eat
itself alive world war ii on the other
side of that coin was more of like a
good versus evil war where you have
Hitler the Nazis the Nazis are always
used as very obvious villains anytime
you want to do a period war movie the
easiest place to go as Nazis because you
automatically root for the other guy so
even though Wonder Woman charging around
on horseback which is going to be
totally awesome with her sword and
shield isn't going to be as much of a
warrior as she is an advocate for peace
but make no mistake someone almost as
powerful as Superman is definitely going
to be kicking a lot of ass so there's
gonna be a whole bunch of fight scenes
bunch of big battles but her ultimate
goal is not going to be twisting
someone's head off like Maxwell Lord
it's going to be making peace so you can
think of this in the way you think of
the Captain America movie the first
Captain
movie has a really fun revisionist
history adventure movie mustard gas
trenches also very easy ways to humanize
the movie just have Wonder Woman see the
horror of all these people just dying in
really muddy graves all over the place
so of course she's going to want to stop
the war most of the stuff we've seen
from the set the behind the scenes stuff
that's leaked has just been them walking
around in costume which actually looked
fantastic all the period costumes look
great not necessarily Nazis but
definitely fighting Germans more awesome
costumes totally dig in her classic
costume if it looks a little bit
different from what it looks like in the
Batman V Superman trailers because
obviously those take place in present
day it's just because they desaturated
the Batman V Superman movie so much I
think that they're pretty close to being
the same I'm assuming the Amazonian
materials that she built her costume
from or just as durable as the
Kryptonian suit that Superman wears you
know maybe not quite exactly the same
thing Wonder Woman has this supernatural
aspect to her so I'm really I'm really
interested to see how they weave that in
because Hippolyta is in the movie the
Amazons are in the movie they're gonna
be pretty true to the comics so we'll
see if she's formed from clay or if
she's born naturally from her mother I'm
really interested to see because she is
part God as of the new 52 she's the
daughter of Zeus in Hippolyta so let's
see what they do with that I'm assuming
that that's going to be the version they
go with they're just going to weave in a
lot of meson send from the Golden Age
comics usually when you see references
to Golden Age comics it's either verbal
or it's visual but a lot of the
backstory a lot of the Canon is derived
from the more modern comics like even on
the Marvel side when they did Captain
America a lot of those Easter eggs
pulled from the Golden Age Captain
America comics but they also
incorporated a lot of stuff from Captain
America rebirth which was a much more
modern reimagining of the character so
I'm assuming the same treatment with
Wonder Woman even though it's a totally
different group of people let me know
what do you think about this movie and
do you think that they're going to be
throwing forward at the end to modern
day so there have been rumors that we
will see like something more modern
something closer to the time of Batman V
Superman towards the end of this film
like it takes place during two different
periods and it seems like based on this
preview most of the movie will be during
World War one era and that makes sense
and I know a lot of you guys are talking
about the Justice League preview they
did - just some of the concept art for
cyborg for the flash it seems like the
Flash's origin story is going to be
pretty close to what it is on the TV
show without the particle accelerator
explosion it's
still the story of Barry getting in the
lab accident being struck by lightning
so it's you know it's true to the comics
but if they're showing this official
preview off to the public that means
that this concept art is probably really
close to what they're going to end up
going with they just expect a few minor
changes I think the next film that I'm
looking forward to most from a character
that we haven't seen a lot from yet
after one or a woman is going to be the
Aquaman movie just um just a memo as a
badass to begin with but just the idea
just the promise of a really badass
Arthur curry character Kevin Smith at
that funny Co where he's like isn't 3/4
of the earth made up of water that's his
domain and it's true it's totally true
so even though there's some creative
limitations to his powers he's almost as
powerful as Superman it's just that
Superman doesn't have quite as many
limitations assuming that you don't have
kryptonite sitting around all over the
place which it sounds like Lex Luthor is
trying to make happen eventually it
seems like he's going to be
experimenting with a lot of Kryptonite
in Batman V Superman so we'll see
because it seemed like there was some
weird kryptonite some weird cosmic
Justice League stuff going on in that
Suicide Squad trailer but we'll have to
find out it might all end up being
mystical enchantress stuff real quick
reminder though if you didn't see any of
the videos that I posted today I'm doing
reverse flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner whenever I post my
flash video hopefully that'll be
sometime later in the morning you should
post pretty quickly so why guess wait
for that next video to post if you
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for the Suicide Squad trailer I just
posted and you can click here for the
last flash arrow trailer I just posted
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight